[Music]
you love smoke we've got no time to
smoke it then come to smoke city the
only store but there's only smoke who
has time to smoke a cigarette there so
long
every day I smoke three hundred
cigarettes and pass the savings on to
you hey yeah two quarts of that Newport
menthols excellent choice sir
[Music]
ha thank you it's that easy
we cut smoking time in half my wife just
had a baby
Japanese cigar smoke boy or girl
it ain't no joke Oh
smoke your smoke
[Applause]
by a jar or take a spin of the smoked
food if it ain't smoke don't fix it
[Music]
damnit smoker
hey you sell crack smoke no okay
like a smoke crack out by your dumpster
you bet
drug smoke not in my store you gotta go
outside for that and I don't sell the
minors unless they're in a very good
disguise come on down we're not just
blowing smoke we're just blowing smoke
down it's okay don't worry about my
health I don't have a family mission
accomplished
that's a horrible act there's no money
to jettison and either he's the worst
guy I've ever seen in my life
and I've seen them all